statement of result at the conclusion of
the count for the Baths constituency as
the acting returning officer for the
election to the parliamentary
constituency of Bath on Thursday the 8th
of June 2017 I hereby certify that the
total number of ballot papers at the
conclusion of this count is 49 thousand
694 the turnout for this constituency is
seventy four point four two percent the
total number of votes given for each of
the candidates is as follows
field Eleanor green party 1125
[Applause]
hope house Fira an addictive Liberal
Democrats 20 3436 Hallett been the
Conservative Party candidates
17700
[Music]
Raymond Jo Labour Party 7279
[Applause]
the total number of votes was forty nine
thousand five hundred and eighty-three
the number of ballot papers rejected at
the first counters as follows wanted an
official mark zero voting for more than
one candidate eighteen voting or mark or
writing or mark by which the voter could
be identified to an unmarked avoid run
1792 the num total number of rejected
ballot papers is 112 I therefore declare
that fear of Benedicta Hobhouse
has been duly elected
[Applause]
first of all I'd like to thank the
acting returning officer her team and
the police for making sure the count ran
so smoothly secondly I would like to
thank my wonderful team who have worked
incredibly hard and have run a very
effective campaign at such short notice
I'd also like to thank the other
candidates and in a field been harlot
and to Raymond
for the respectful manner in which the
election was fought but most of all I
want to thank you the people of Bath for
voting for me I'm so honored that you
have chosen me to represent you I will
work hard to be an MP for the whole city
including those who don't currently get
their fair share of our city's
prosperity I look forward for serving
this city has Don Foster did so well for
23 years
[Music]
[Applause]
I will listen to and stand up for
residents who feel left behind by the
conservative conservative government and
the conservative Council I'll stand up
to get a better funding deal for our
schools and for our NHS and finally I
will make sure we don't cut ourselves
off from our European neighbors we must
avoid a bad deal that cripples our
economy removes our rights and threatens
our security something that would be bad
for all of us whether you voted leave or
remain I will stand up for the